ein computer chip der gehirnfunktion
imitiert könnte künstlicher intelligenz
zum durchbruch verhelfen
der neueste ansatz für ki abstrahiert
die prinzipien der neurowissenschaften
und passt sie an die praktische
computertechnologie an
damit könnten rechner demnächst fast so
funktionieren wir unsere menschlichen
gehirne und sie würden atemberaubende
geschwindigkeiten erreichen klicks um
science-fiction jedes steak die
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen im sn 1054 nettop von unserem
wissenschafts netzwerk haben jacobs
hattrick und ich ja schon intensiv
darüber diskutiert die forschung an
künstlicher intelligenz entwickelt sich
rasant und liefert ständig neue und
bahnbrechende entwicklung eine davon
soll jetzt von intel kommt intel baut
computerchips diese prozessoren können
mit der richtigen programmierung extrem
schnell und präzise rechnen aber andere
aufgaben wie zum beispiel assoziationen
oder das erkennen von mustern und
zusammenhängen bewältigen sie nicht so
schnell solche aufgaben können sie nur
mit erheblichem aufwand lösen dafür muss
ein computer nämlich jedes mal daten aus
einer datenbank abrufen und bereits
bekannte fälle vergleichen das liegt
einfach an der architektur unserer
heutigen computer speicher und prozessor
sind hier zwei getrennte einheiten um
das zu ändern strebt der weltweit größte
halbleiterhersteller intel jetzt ein
völlig neues chipdesign an neuromorphic
computing nennt intel seine neue
technologie mit der computer chips
gehirnfunktion imitieren die
neurologischen chips bilden die
verdrahtung von neuronen mit synapsen
nach und anders als bisher vereinen sie
speicher und prozessor wenn wir lernen
werden zwischen unserer nervenzellen
über diesen ups in unserem gehirn neue
verbindung hergestellt und genau das
sollen auch die chips mit den
künstlichen neuronen und synapsen können
sie ahmen unsere grundlegenden
hirnfunktionen nach um das maschinelle
lernen schneller und effizienter zu
machen
der forschungs chip von intel besitzt
dazu 130000 künstliche neuronen aus
silizium die sich abhängig von der
jeweiligen anwendung selbstständig
verknüpfen die neuronen wiederum sind zu
8192 neuromorphic kern zusammengefasst
so kann die funktionsweise
des hirns in einem prozessor
nachgebildet werden indem so ein chip
gespeicherte daten zur weiterentwicklung
seiner fähigkeiten nutzt lernt das chip
kontinuierlich weiter und wird immer
intelligenter und somit auch effizienter
der konzern verfolgt mit seinem chip das
ziel computer noch leistungsfähiger zu
machen genauer gesagt sollen sie
anwendungen 1000 mal schneller und
10.000 mal effizienter bewältigen
das bedeutet auch dass der
stromverbrauch drastisch gesenkt werden
kann nicht nur bei der technik hat intel
sich übrigens die natur zum vorbild
genommen auch bei der namensgebung des
neurotischen forschungsschiffs denen die
leute kauften kommt das vorbild aus der
natur neu ist der name eines
unterseeischen vulkans vor der küste
hawaiis der 3000 meter hohe vulkan also
3000 meter unter der meeresoberfläche
liegt zwar noch etwa ein kilometer unter
der wasseroberfläche aber
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass er
eines tages an die oberfläche kommt
genau wie der gigantische koloss aus dem
meer soll auch der neue chip eines tages
ans licht kommen und mit seinen
technologievorsprung für gewaltiges
aufsehen in der branche sorgen und hier
gehts zum nerd talk über kai wird
künstliche genc die menschheit umbringen
anklicken anschauen am besten alle drei
kanäle breaking lab doktor watson und
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran